welcome back to new rockstars I'm Eric
Boston adventures in games digital
release is squeezing out Easter eggs
faster than that spider that laid eggs
in my ear I didn't get superpowers
unless you count and some Nia but the
other reason I got spiders on the brain
is the latest and most interesting
Easter Egg people have spotted in the
final minutes of their in-game rewatch
is a possible Quinn Stasi cameo at Peter
Parker's high school Pig backpack blonde
hair web pattern skirts look directly on
the camera and said I am spider-gwen
made up that last one but still pretty
close to a dead ringer now this has not
been confirmed and probably won't be but
between this little cameo and other
miserable clues and spider-man far from
home Marvel could still have plans for
gwen stacy to play a role in Peter
Parker story in the third spider-man
film be it titled home Rex hometown hero
homesick hold onto those butts because
I'm diving deep to explain why this
extra who wore her favorite Hot Topic
skirt is now the most important person
of all time spoiler warning the case
unhinged speculation accidentally
stumbles into accurate predictions and
that triggers future you so let's talk
about maybe Quinn here yes that web
patterned skirt is quite the fashion
statement in an MCU film that is
littered with meaningful Easter eggs but
as of this moment this person is not
Gwen Stacy her skirt and hair color
could be a reference to the character
but when Stacy of course does not appear
anywhere in the Avengers endian credits
there's not even anything like blonde
Midtown high school student with
potential chemistry to Tom Holland in a
future movie the character of Gwen Stacy
along with pretty much all of
spider-man's supporting characters and
villains is a property of Sony Studios
Marvel Studios Co produces the MCU
spider-man films homecoming far from
home with Sony has part of a special
deal that they've negotiated which
allows Peter Parker and some other
characters to also appear in other MCU
movies like Civil War infinity war and
in war so Ferg when Stacy does show up
an endgame that would require a huge
negotiation between Marvel and Sony and
for whatever Marvel would have to pay
for the rights to show Gwen Stacy in
their movie I think they want to get a
little more out of this little cameo
than this
wanna beg cameo it's hard to determine
who this actress even is going off of
IMDB which is not the most legit source
you can see some actors crediting
themselves on the movie as Midtown high
student or just student some kind of
resemble this maybe Gwen here also
there's just some logic issues here and
the cow makes Quinn Stacey was initially
introduced as a classmate of Peter
Parker in college at Empire State
University not back in high school and
then there's the alternate universe
earth 65 where Gwen Stacy becomes
spider-gwen
after Peter becomes that universes
version of the lizard dies and then
you'll remember Gwen Stacy's showing up
and into the spider-verse as a classmate
of Miles Morales at the Brooklyn visions
Academy in earth 1610 there's just a lot
to work out either way if Gwen Stacy did
have spider powers here it would be
pretty dumb for her to walk around in a
spiderweb skirt it'd be like a Peter
Parker had a pet tarantula not smart if
you're trying to say discreet so I think
we're just looking at one of the many
spider-man fans who attend Peters school
much like our boy Flash Thompson now
that said I could totally see a future
spider-man movie introducing Gwen Stacy
in some new way and then going back to
retcon this moment as an example of her
already existing in the MCU kind of like
what Kevin Feige suggested that that kid
in the Iron Man mask that Tony Stark
save in Iron Man 2 was actually a young
Peter Parker but this list of the
question of why would when Stacy need to
be introduced doesn't Peter already have
a girlfriend with MJ and an arguably
even more intimate soulmate connection
with Ned yes but in the Indiana
spider-man far from home and another
spoiler warning if you're an idiot still
sticking with this despite not seen a
movie yet Peter Parker was outed as
spider-man with Jay jonah Jameson
playing Mysterio's doctored video in
framing Peter Parker so now that Peter
has been exposed those closest to him
might have to distance themselves MJ Ned
Aunt May anyone who was previously
openly friendly with Peter who would now
be under public scrutiny and possible
criminal investigation since they had
been aiding and abetting that public
menace spider-man that could force Peter
to turn to new relationships new friends
new something Morris previously relative
nobodies with less heat on them like
going the guste see that girl in the web
Peter never gave a second glance and
probably recast as someone more famous
no offense to the extra on that Indian
set Peters time off grid might also lead
him to other figures like Flash Thompson
if you watch far from home closely you
might have noticed that flash is clearly
being set up to play a greater role in
the next film on the tour bus Peters
Edith glasses revealed Flash texting his
mother that he hadn't heard from her or
father in days and then at the end of
the film flash looked super dejected
what his parents did not pick him up at
the airport now you could just read into
this stuff as like a running side joke
the kind of mean-spirited sad side joke
but it has led to some speculation that
flash could end up being a Harry Osborn
type figure a wealthy companion to Peter
Parker who ends up taking a villainous
turn others have pointed out that in
some versions of the venom comics Flash
Thompson does take on the symbiote
himself with people thinking that this
flash could set up a venom crossover
like maybe his mom was missing because
she was busy working for worst boss ever
Carlton Drake at the light foundation
flash actor Tony River Laurie joked with
friends at a private far from home
screening about his future role yeah
that one was probably a joke but Flash's
bigger role in the third movie could be
another companion to off the grid Peter
Parker a spider-man superfan who
publicly never really got along with
that loser Peter Parker but now the
flash knows the two are the same could
maintain deniability secretly using his
means to help Peter or if you believe
that venom crossover Theory maybe
there's an emotionally broken flash who
finds companionship with the fugitive
Peter Parker after Flash's mother
literally took her work home with her
with Peter struggling to clear his name
and flash disrupting that with a
dangerous toxic symbiote that threatens
to infect Peter as well look folks it's
not too crazy to consider flash being
used to bring in elements like venom or
Harry Osborn storylines considering
these spider-man movies have already
established crossovers like Jay jonah
Jameson Miles Morales and Prowler and
perhaps now Gwen Stacy how do you think
spider Gwynn should be introduced into
the MCU and
would you rather spider-man 3 bring in
the sinister six or venom comment down
below with your thoughts follow me on
Instagram and Twitter at Ieva
and subscribe to new rock stars or
breakdown some theories about everything
marvel thank you for joining me and
weird otherwise if you ever get a gig as
an extra on any Marvel movie be sure to
dress up as your favorite currently
uncashed it's superhero like a Reed
Richards for shirts some Wolverine
sideburns maybe a backpack with
extendable Doc Ock arms seriously
whatever you can get away with because
we will make you a star
[Music]